[Music]  new this afternoon an arrest made in a  sexual assault case in the northwest  part of town  it happened last monday near lake mead  and torrey pines  metro tells us the suspect 18-year-old  laparese jones is facing several charges  after authorities say he attacked a  woman while she was out walking her dog  he's accused of trying to strangle her  before sexually assaulting her  collaborative effort from many members  of the las vegas metropolitan police  department  and many members of the community is  what led to the arrest of mr laprezi  jones  jones is in custody in the clark county  detention center scheduled to appear in  court tomorrow morning at 9.